we assume that you won't be making any
definitive decisions about your future
after the release of this ag report
regardless of what's set in it and
instead you're going to wait
until the impeachment inquiry is done in
the state assembly and my second
question is
whether or not you would support an ag
investigation specifically
into the alleged nursing home cover-up
as families in foley square today
are protesting and demanding yeah
nursing homes
is being looked at by the eastern
district
that was a political investigation
started by donald trump
who politicized not just covet but then
politicized nursing homes and policies
towards nursing homes and wanted to
blame democratic governors like myself
and michigan and new jersey
and pennsylvania it was all our fault
and then had his political department of
justice start an investigation
and they were a political department of
justice there was no doubt about that
so that's being done by the department
of justice
and i've already told new yorkers uh
where i am i did nothing wrong
and uh period and i'm not resigning and
i'm doing my job every day